[Music]
good idea welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight there were two special elections
in the state of North Carolina last
night both them were billed as close
races in the end Republicans won both of
them and they won handily in the more
competitive race in the ninth district
Republican Dan Bishop finished
substantially better than the last
Republican who ran during the midterms
just ten months ago so what does that
tell us well on Twitter the debate is
about Donald Trump as it always is on
Twitter how much did his rally North
Carolina on Monday night influence the
outcome of the election there's no
question it did influence it positively
it helped the Republicans but there's
another factor at play here that's
received far less attention the
Democratic debates the debates have been
televised and that means the rest of the
country gets to hear what leading
Democrats actually believe it turns out
that's been terrifying to many people
could give you a lot of examples of this
but we'll start with this one how many
people would you have to survey go to
the mall or a park any public place and
ask people how many would you have to
talk to you before you've found a single
person who supports giving free
taxpayer-funded healthcare to foreign
nationals who've snuck into our country
and who are living here illegally you
have to talk to a lot of people before
you found someone in favor of that
almost nobody in America supports that
and for good reason because it's nuts
and not something we can afford and yet
all the major Democratic candidates say
they do support it watch this so you
support giving universal health care and
Medicare for all to people who are in
this country illegally let me just be
very clear about this I am opposed to
any policy that would deny in our
country any human being from access to
public safety public education or public
health period do you believe that
undocumented people should have health
care in this country I think on
documented people need to have a means
by which they can be covered when
they're sick people need this is just
common decency we use your hand if
covered if your government plan would
provide coverage for undocumented
uh-huh if you're a middle-class person
who can barely afford to get sick who is
struggling for example as so many art to
pay the premiums on your health
insurance imagine what they're telling
you they're saying that people who
aren't from here who have no right to be
are here who are breaking our laws by
their presence get ahead of you in line
that's just the beginning by the way at
various other times the Democratic
candidates have told us they want to put
hundreds of thousands of criminals back
onto the streets they bragged about
decriminalizing all illegal border
crossings they've embraced the most
aggressive form of identity politics as
well as the weirdest kind of gender
theology they've relentlessly attacked
America is evil and described a person's
worth as defined by gender and skin
color the opposite of the American Dream
they've endorsed taxpayer-funded
abortion up to the moment of birth
here's betta or org someone asks you
specifically specifically about third
tone third trimester abortions and you
said that it's the decision left up left
up to the mother so my question is this
I was born September 8 1989 and I want
to know if you think on September 7th
1981 89 my life had no value of course I
don't think that and of course I'm glad
that you're here this is a decision that
neither you nor I nor the United States
government should be making that's a
decision for the woman to make meanwhile
any Democrat and there are some who
urges the party to focus on the
practical concerns of mainstream
Americans anyone who says that is
treated like a leper like they're
unclean they're met either with total
silence or worse they get a lecture from
Elizabeth Warren I think when we run on
real solutions not impossible promises
when we run on things that are workable
not fairy tale economics you know I
don't understand why anybody does to all
the trouble of running
President of the United States just to
talk about what we really can't do and
shouldn't fight for well moments like
that kill on Twitter all the Twitter
people love it in real life though
they're a surefire way to lose votes
most Americans don't hate America they
know we're not a racist country that
needs to be rebuilt from the ground up
most Americans are cheerful and moderate
and the polls show it an NPR poll from
two months ago for example found that
less than 30 percent of voters wanted to
decriminalize border crossings or pay
out reparations for slavery just 41
percent wanted to replace private health
insurance with Medicare for all America
this spring found that only 18 percent
of Americans agree with bado that
abortion ought to be available for any
reason up until birth in other words the
Democratic Party is almost perfectly in
sync with the population of Martha's
Vineyard the summertime population not
the wintertime population but the party
is gravely out of step with the rest of
the country and that's why they lost
last night in fact that's why they'll
lose again next November unless they
stop talking like that and move to the
center fast